[Applause]
[Music]
19:49 I started at my blindness
I had 20/20 vision will not be driving
and all the cars would come they go Iowa
I couldn't say
focus it takes a great deal of courage
on the part of the patient to become
involved in a study like this we're
taking people that have no light
perception and we're attempting to
restore some level of vision the doctor
and he real close several times
dignitary changes that occur in the
peripheral retina gave the disease its
name he said Joey I'm going to go have
to tune this Thompson stroke warrant and
he called my daddy
I spent the day there with all kinds of
things the rod and cone cells in the
retina D generate they're not causes
News office
the earliest symptom is night blindness
that next is tunnel vision he told me
that I had got not as pigmentosum and I
didn't need to be having any more
children and I didn't need to be driving
anymore and that was fat so I went home
and had to tell my husband you give it a
nice freedom oh he cried tears rolled
down his cheeks he said that he's dead
Joakim ample monsters
although here's notice the way this
array works is that it is placed on the
surface of the retina on the inner
surface of the retina on the inside of
the eye the array really does not have
any direct effect on the rod and cone
cells and in retinitis pigmentosa the
Rodney cone cells are completely
degenerated so what we're doing with the
array is we're stimulating areas of the
retina that are downstream from the rod
and cone cells specifically we're
stimulating a layer called the ganglion
cell layer and they form the optic
nerves and directly sends impulses to
the brain
I would like to be able to stay on my
children my bridge just love to see the
beauty of nature however people talk to
me about what they're saying and some
areas I can picture my mouth because
I've been so blessed to be able to see
it my turn
[Music]
[Applause]